[Music]
all right so uh i wanted to bring this
one up because we've actually talked
about this dude on jk news before and
unfortunately there's a little bit of a
tragic update oh do you guys remember
the brazilian hulk no no oh yeah yeah
yeah you do oh the guy who put a bunch
of synthol in his body oh you tell me he
died
what the [ __ ] you're telling me oh he
started the inflection
oh you're telling me he died oh man that
is really sad but [ __ ]
he died guys he puts like synthol in his
did his heart tuck her out what happened
really you know where you know where he
[ __ ] up the synthol it should have
been olive oil
olive oil see
cause i read that olive oil is actually
good for you but all these other oils
like corn oil canola oil
synthol can't cook with that older oil
hey i got a very low smoke what the [ __ ]
is synthol synthetic oil okay there it
is this is a brazilian bodybuilder who's
known for injecting an oil solution into
his muscles he's just died at the age of
55. his name is valdir sagato also known
as a brazilian hulk hey but he was he
died jack though
oh yeah
like right when he died he just like
came out of his ass but do you think he
lifts though
like what if he's weak ass [ __ ] he's
just being he's carrying them shits
around all day that is lifting yeah
that's true so he's been warned by
doctors that his methods of looking so
big could create health complications
um he was pretty much what happened he
recently asked for help from a neighbor
and complained about shortness of breath
um it was a heart attack it was around 6
00 am more or less he came crawling
through the back house of his neighbor
came to the front then he knocked on his
mother's window
the neighbor's mother's window knocked
and she woke up and he said help me help
me because i'm dying oh that's uh too
real too that's really yeah that's true
that's real he knocks it sounds like a
[ __ ] grenade's going off like that
his arms are jacked jacked he was taken
to the north emergency care unit for
treatment they put him in the car and
then the neighbor went to the epa he
arrived and he fell at the reception so
you were saying that when you inject
that has nothing to do it doesn't make
you any stronger right no no it's purely
cosmetic yeah so that food is a [ __ ]
honda accord with a massive spoiler on
the back
with type r
he's a type r handler now you put like
three stickers on and you think you
faster
it's more like it's more like a [ __ ]
minivan that puts spinning rims on
i wonder how many years he's been doing
this been doing for a minute he said he
was influenced so basically he was
influenced by the size arnold
schwarzenegger and the incredible hulk
uh had and he clearly wanted to do
whatever he could to imitate them walk i
mean he could just [ __ ] work out
really hard eat a lot of people just do
steroids like everybody else dude is
arnold natty no no he's not that famous
what's nanny
if he's not on oh [ __ ] no he's on
steroids hello he's admitted to then
coming that's what he said has he
admitted to it the pump is better than
coming that's what he says all the time
uh he managed to get his super human
looks thanks to injecting his muscles
with a concoction consisting of oil
alcohol and painkillers
experts warned oh that's not a good
[ __ ] job painkillers yeah his risk of
stroke infections abscesses and even amp
wait he made a mix of oil alcohol and
painkiller but no mention of olive oil
see like i don't understand why you
would inject alcohol
i don't think it's like um [ __ ]
captain morgan or anything like that
it's like
painkillers
this guy made his own concoction for
sure
he hadn't injected the synthol solution
in a while however he wasn't ruling it
out in the future as he wanted to make
his breasts even larger
he was first warned back in 2016 that
his concerning approach could cause
disfigurement nerve and muscle damage
and a plethora of other nasty outcomes i
want to see what he sees like when he
goes into the mirror does he see like a
[ __ ] scrawny ass dude and he goes i
need to get the beaker he did he does
you know what here's where it all comes
from there's always a backstory for
people right uh he said that he he was
given the name skin of the nickname
skinny dog back when he was younger
and that probably [ __ ] with him so
clearly he wanted to shed that moniker
and he went above and beyond to leave
that image oh man it's so real dude dead
buff guy so so he starts hitting the gym
but quickly realized that the results he
was aiming for wouldn't come with just
healthy eating and weight training so
there's probably a point where he
actually probably looked good yeah he
won't look decent but he wasn't arnold
sourcing this morphe it's fine so when
he was offered synthol
by someone at his gym he took it
yeah so it's very important to know kind
of like really the back story of like
people's decision making like if you're
in your own mind whether it's body
dysmorphia or trauma you know i mean
from people giving you a nickname like
skinny dog calling you like fat or
whatever it is that could for the weaker
mind
lead into something else and apparently
this guy also
has an addictive personality it also
sucks to be that [ __ ] gateway homie
that's like hey try this yeah like dude
do you want to get more
i think it's better to look past all
that and just judge him and say that he
was really stupid for doing that and
that's more fun
that's more fun yeah yeah of course we
think that he makes you real by showing
us his trauma yeah of course of course
we know that his body dysmorphias stem
from trauma i think guys like this
should date girls that have multiple
plastic surgeries on their face and
their [ __ ] titties and stuff where
they get those big titties i think they
feel big that it like sags to their
kneecaps yeah because otherwise his
titties are bigger than any other chicks
is there anything
attractive about that look to you julia
raydom one of them have you seen the big
boob girls i'm talking about it's a
genre
their boobs are so huge
i don't think you know this but it's a
joke they're almost always biker chicks
too almost always biker chicks he's not
even like he doesn't even look as crazy
as some of those like dude look at his
[ __ ] tits man yeah that's correct and
then it's weird because he didn't even
inject his legs he just looks like a
like when a kid tries to draw a wrestler
and you [ __ ] the proportions up you're
like get this [ __ ] out of here
he could have just used photoshop too i
don't think that's attractive it just
looks it just looks way too big you
don't like big dudes you don't like big
[ __ ] strong dudes
super muscular you all like big news
what's your ideal male body type um
out of the five of us
i'm just kidding
ryan was included
out of the slime no no no no no
no you don't want to know no way you
guys okay yes yes we want to know don't
include me
if yoshi was here yeah she answers yoshi
100 oh yeah yeah yeah she has nine yeah
bart's booty for sure
i haven't seen it yet so i don't want to
say
ass in the game literally jocking it
every day that's a natty ass too
i straight molest bar like i slap his
ass we can't call because i want
something from him yes absolutely you
ever seen that kim kardashian thing
where you [ __ ] bottled like a wine
glass on his ass yeah yeah
and on his tits too i need to see that
on jk news i need to i'm just waiting
for the day when bart really needs money
[Laughter]
you're always you know what i want i'm
always checking in yeah
how's that balance
oh come on say something nice about
bart's butt dude don't make it weird
bart's butt man he's kind of big but
don't make it weird oh you might not say
something he got a big button in my
movie joe's like actually really into
bart and he's like he's like no no he
necks them dude
it's not even that big yeah
yeah yeah
i like the way you guys are talking
about him like that no we gotta respect
him a little bit more
that's true
that's you out of my all my years of
working with them there is some form of
bromance between them maybe a little bit
more every time we [ __ ] talk about
bart's meat like joseph gets all
quiet slow zoom and the music kicks in
you can hear a [ __ ] mouse eating in
the corner
that's how you really find the leaks in
the building
just bring them in and talk about bars
that's it it's like oh i heard
everything
no really his ass is amazing it's pretty
crazy do you know what his workout is
like
the get lean program yeah
i know it's really really early
it's really early and i have to start
like 3 25 in the morning
you gotta you gotta get to sleep by like
9 30 p.m you won't get jacked if you
don't start it like 1 15. you always got
to sleep like this you got to sleep
upright you can't sleep would you ever
get any cosmetic surgery
no
if you had to what would be the first
thing yeah what part of your face you're
like i [ __ ] hate this [ __ ]
i gotta fix it or would you do any like
anti-aging ones like botox in 15 years
or some [ __ ] like that yeah
no i don't know right now things like
okay okay classic asian [ __ ] right like
uh eyebrow tattoo no not even
like an asian mom put like over here
a lip filler slight lip
filler good that one's [ __ ] up i think
lipsticks are fun raising the cheekbone
thing or or shaving the the jawline oh
man those are crazy nuts it's very
common though
there are moments where i do feel like
that like my face is like perfect the
way it is no no no no no no
[Applause]
there are moments where i feel like my
face is wide but when i really think
about
wanting to win when do you think this
cosmetics i don't know sometimes it's
just like when i think about cosmetic
surgery i like i look at my face and i'm
like
i actually like the way that i look like
hey
thanks
all right judge our faces is our face
no tearless tearless on faces diagnose
us with cosmetic surgery don't say don't
say you don't say you would fix my face
with a fist i know okay how about this
oh my god how about this who would dream
i would be a boot
who would benefit the most here from a
nose job go a no-show
i'd i want one and be harsh flat asian
nose
you got a flat asian nose looks like
someone need me in the face you probably
somebody didn't shut up dude that never
happened okay
actually everyone here's got a nice nose
okay look who has the best ears in the
room
[Laughter]
and let's go let's go let's go
counterclockwise damn dude
you're going
hey nick did you know my earlobes hell
is stretch look
yeah
that's really good who doesn't want to
hang on that's like a buddha style yeah
um i think buddha style who doesn't say
that you have like a lot of good fortune
when it stretches i think they say i'm
immortal when it's just like really long
like
yeah you got money they kind of bounce
when you talk
yeah they said that it's a sign of long
life or cancer so it's nice okay good
nice it's like ear cleavage
oh yeah dude so so if we pick a cosmetic
surgery for each of us yeah we can all
benefit from that please come on no
holds barred literally the worst person
because i just like how everyone looks
in general oh hey wow wow that's brave
that's really brave oh yeah
treat me though honest question though
nick yeah yeah honest question you got
[ __ ] free cosmetics would you be like
would you drain your ears never because
it's like it's who you are and if you
don't get it it's not even from who i am
it's because i do train a lot so it's
like no matter what it was kind of go
back probably but do you feel like more
of a man it will it doesn't go away no i
think it's a cool [ __ ] thing because
then people don't [ __ ] with you yeah i
think it's i think it's because of how
ufc's taken off it's seen as like oh
[ __ ] i've seen two guys at a bar yelling
at each other that they were gonna fight
and the insults they were saying was
like look how [ __ ] pretty your eyes
are you don't [ __ ] fight and the
other or his ears and the other guy's
all look at your ears those are the
[ __ ] prettiest ears i ever [ __ ]
seen they were talking [ __ ] like that
yeah saying calling each other's ears
pretty you should have kicked both their
[ __ ] is that cool it's like how they
do they clip the doberman ears to make
as like a warning like that's what this
[ __ ] is i didn't know that that's like
an insult to call someone's ears pretty
kicked by like fifty percent of the
people oh i do too 100 i think you get
[ __ ] laid out when i was a kid i i
wanted
uh plastic surgery you know how people
want to fix things
i wanna
yeah
you could do that for free on your own
why did you do it it hurts
i had someone though
elementary and then you sing like jeremy
irons or whatever [ __ ]
scar as soon as i got an injury in
elementary school i have one here i had
i was like oh it's [ __ ] coming to
life bro i got one coming out right here
that was every cool henchman yeah
scarred the uncle scar
the lion so if you got a if you got a
voucher for free cosmetic surgery and
you have to use it or else flint will
never get clean water what would you do
you can't make your dick bigger okay
that was that was my first yeah yeah
yeah
you have to do something something or
pasadena explodes yup
wait no no my god it's not my city
it's like i want double eyelid surgery
oh
it kind of has something going on i get
another dimple how about that i only
have one on one side
okay that's one that's cool because i
was like that's i'm a freak for having
one
so i should get two i would get i would
get george clooney chan oh wait wait i
want to change my mind
[Laughter]
oh yeah i want to change my dude jordan
get that george
oh i would i would just grow i would put
uh hair plugs right here yeah
so you can [ __ ] grow a [ __ ] beard
like a thick russian beard he just looks
like wolverine
i think you look good in a beard do you
think so i look like a 10th planet i
can't grow one you you would look older
than like a teenager
wait look at my food man true bro
i was like
i get a face plant like [ __ ] nicolas
cage face off
whose face would you get john travolta's
face
you